bonsoir lyon donc je suis
game designer je conçois des jeux vidéo
l'industrie des l'industrie du jeu vidéo
est une industrie vraiment
extraordinaire mais personnellement je
m'éclate et elle est extrêmement jeune
donc elle est comment dire l on est en
train encore de définir les règles et
particulièrement il ya quelque chose
donc déjà une petite introduction sur
l'industrie en elle même donc
l'industrie
c'est quelques dizaines de milliards de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires par an et
c'était en 2014 500 jeux vidéo publiée
par jour uniquement sur mobile donc
c'est une quantité énorme de production
culturelle et pourtant on parle d'haïti
donc de propriété intellectuelle dans le
jeu vidéo le droit de la propriété
intellectuelle ne ne protège pas le jeu
vidéo
il protège des petits bouts de jeux
vidéo c'est à dire qu'on peut protéger
un texte
on peut protéger un éventuellement une
forme de graphisme soudain on va dire un
certain cadre peut protéger la musique
mais on peut voir protéger le jeu vidéo
en tant qu'entité compact et on peut pas
surtout protéger le coeur du jeu vidéo
qui est le gameplay donc corollaire on
peut tous se copier les uns sur les
autres et on est dans une industrie du
plagiat et c'est un laboratoire
expérimental extraordinaire à la
creative common imaginez que demain on
puisse se copier les uns sur les autres
dans la musique ou dans le graphisme et
bien c'est possible c'est ce qui se
passe dans jeux vidéo et comment ça se
passe bah ça se passe très bien
c'est à dire que plein de jeux sortent
effectivement il a beaucoup qui se
ressemblent les uns sur les autres et
vous avez dû voir ça
effectivement on parle de clown c'est à
dire que vous pouvez voir 50 mille dix
mille clown d'un jeu qui sort et y en a
qu'un seul qui va marcher on est dans la
loterie mais ça a des vertus des vertus
extrêmement intéressantes comme par
exemple parfois il est très bon jeu au
fil des itérations où on est obligé de
décaler la valeur ajoutée sur du
marketing de la commercialisation et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui le jeu
vidéo est un secteur où il ya des moyens
d'acheter ou des moyens de vendre qui
sont extrêmement en avance par rapport à
d'autres secteurs qui sont à dire très
rigide et très protégés par des avocats
également alors une petite anecdote
quand les joueurs d'échecs de haut
niveau jouer entre eux les premiers
échanges de coups s'est jamais ils
réfléchissent pas ils sont en mode
automatique parce que ils font des
ouvertures qui connaissent par coeur et
donc les 10-15 premiers couilles pièce
juste dans des bibliothèques mémorial
dans lequel ils prennent les meilleurs
coups et bien aujourd'hui dans la
création de jeux vidéo on fonctionne à
un petit peu comme ça c'est à dire que
quand on confie la création d'un jeu je
commence par piocher les premières
briques donc ce que je connais de gestes
qui existent qui sont des idées qui ont
été validés par le marché et par le
passé et après on commence à creuser une
différence en termes d'innovation donc
c'est vraiment un secteur où ça se passe
très très bien
là maintenant je vous parlait d une
chose très particulière qui correspond à
1 % de mon chiffre d'affaires et qui
correspond à 30% de mon travail
intellectuel c'est le live et ce qui est
donc le escape qui en a une à lyon on a
10 15 ha à paris c'est un parc
d'attractions donc flipper pas sympa
d'être dans lequel on vous vous enferme
dans une pièce avec des amis vous avez
une heure pour en sortir en ferme la
porte à clé et vous avez une heure pour
trouver la clé qui est caché derrière
des henning à des pièces gâchis et des
coffres trésor et des femmes c'est je
peux pas rentrer dans le détail parce
que c'est un peu confidentiel mais en
gros c'est un mini-parc d'attractions et
aujourd'hui alors il ya quelques années
ça n'existait pas du tout en france
pourra pour tout dire ça vient de
budapest est aujourd'hui à budapest ses
47 la fsk ees plus que des salles de
cinéma et donc il ya quelques années une
jeune fille vient me voir et me dit ah
tu construis des henning c'est bien un
cycle et chloé je veux créer la première
live escape en france à paris et là
j'avais un problème j'ai déjà j'avais
pas une thune donc j'étais obligé
d'accepter et en plus je pouvais pas la
budapest faut voir comment c'était et
j'avais un vrai problème qui était qu'
on avait rien sur quoi se fondent et
c'est à dire que pour la première fois
dans mon métier de créateur de jeu bah
je devais partir de rien et ça nous a
pris deux ans et demi voilà aujourd'hui
on aujourd'hui le modèle a été validée
ça a été aussi compliqué d'un point de
vue entreprenariale pour elle de créer
sa société parce que business model
était et est vue d'un mauvais oeil par
les banquiers
donc comment créer à partir de rien et
ça va être l'essentiel de ce que je vais
vous confier aujourd'hui je peux pas
vous dire ce que j'ai créée par ce que
c'est
c'est un mystère pourrait venir à paris
et l'a testé mais je peux vous dire
comment je vais créer cercle et quelle
est la technique que j'ai utilisé la
méthodologie qui aujourd'hui que
j'utilise pour créer mes jeux parfois je
me plante est en tout cas c'est elle que
j'utilise la première chose qui est très
importante
s'il faut prendre son temps c'est à dire
que si demain je vous donne toutes les
clés et je vous match tout le boulot
pour faire votre projet quel qu'il soit
votre projet va pas voir dame si vous
prenez pas le temps nécessaire pour le
vol appropriés intellectuellement le
travailler et le travail sur tous ces
plans et souvent c'est pas simplement de
la conception c'est par exemple quand on
dit marketing la communication ça c'est
des choses qui prennent beaucoup de
temps donc il faut prendre son temps si
vous en avez la possibilité
la deuxième chose et là il faut vous
réveiller parce que c'est la chose la
plus importante de ce que je vais vous
dire après vous pouvez vous rendormir
c'est il faut définir à lexique et une
grammaire donc vous allez avancé dans
l'inconnu et vous vous allez avoir
énormément de mal à savoir de quoi même
vous êtes en train de parler avoue même
quand vous allez créer vos choses donc
il faut pour prendre des mots
complètement arbitraire et d'ailleurs
c'est ce que je fais enfin des énigmes
je les appelle des puzzles parce que
c'est le terme anglais par exemple mais
j'ai tout un vous pouvez les appeler des
pots de fleurs peu importe mais
l'important c'est que vous puissiez
avoir un référent interne et dès que
vous créez un au système une nouvelle
articulation dans votre projet il faut
que vous puissiez le nommer précisément
ça c'est un outil qui vous fait gagner
du temps d'une façon incroyable ensuite
ça c'est assez amusant vous posez des
raids règles complètement arbitraire out
of nowhere et vous vous y tenez même si
elles sont absurdes par exemple j'ai
posé une règle dès le départ qu'ils
étaient soixante soixante minutes 60
énigme c'est une règle qui marche pas du
tout mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que je les fais et j'ai posé un certain
nombre de règles donc un codex de règles
ce qui m'a permis de produire quelque
chose qui ne fonctionnait pas dans un
premier temps mais c'est comme les
crêpes la première s'est jamais la bonne
mais ce qui est très intéressant c'est
qu'il y avait une cohérence interne une
homogénéité et quand on a commencé face
au premier bêta test à voir que ça
marchait pas on en changeant n'est pas
simplement la sfio ça marche tellement
changé tout le reste de façon à garder
cette cohérence
donc vous vous fixer des règles peu
importe vous savez qu'elles seront
quels sont à changer ça c'est aussi
important de pouvoir remettre en
question les règles qu'on a fait et vous
vous y tenez pour garder votre cohérence
interne ensuite observer l'univers de
travail donc ça c'est un c'est quelque
chose qui a un petit peu technique mais
je vous le dis ce sera bon pour être
culture générale donc dans le monde du
jeu vidéo
on a on a on a un dicton qui dit
observer l'univers de travail et les
principes de gameplay émergeront de même
c'est à dire que vous allez faire un
projet quel qu'il soit qui sera
forcément très abstrait au début parce
que vous aurez rien je vous donnais une
thématique générale dans le cadre d'un
parc d'attractions ça peut être les
pirates les zombies les alice au pays
des merveilles peu importe
et à ce moment là vous allez aussi avoir
une cohérence dans votre travail une
homogénéité dans tout ce que vous sortez
vous avez juste à vous asseoir on est
dans un coin de votre pièce de votre
thématique et de regarder ce qu'il ya
dans la thématique d'aller souper des
maris et des champignons géants il ya un
charme et les énigmes que vous casser la
tête pour ça fait deux mois que vous
cherchez l'abonné ning elles viendront
d'elles-mêmes
tout va devenir naturellement en fait on
retranscrit le monde à travers un jeu
ensuite
autre point quand je livre un travail et
je livre une live et ce club en
particulier mais ça marche aussi pour
les jeux vidéo je livre une couche
abstraite une couche concrète c'est à
dire que parallèlement jeudi par exemple
à l'étape 4 les joueurs vont entrer dans
le lieu c'est et vont découvrir l'objet
48 47 49 et après ça c'est la couche
abstraite et en dessous je dis je
j'écris la région la chose de façon
concrète donc à cette étape les joueurs
vont trouver une pièce cachée dans cette
cache cache et ils vont décorer un
coffre dans ce coffre et une clé
anglaise
ce qui fait que quand on arrive au
prototypage et quand on réalise les
choses des fois que créer une pièce ça
peut avoir cent mille euros de budget
donc c'est des budgets qui sont pas
anodins ben parfois on peut pas créer la
pièce cachée parce que il n'ya pas c'est
pas possible donc dans ce cas
particulier donc on remonte sur la
couche abstraite et on l'a on transforme
dit bon on peut pas faire de cas se
cacher on mettra une caisse qui sera
fermée on fera autre chose
je n'ose exemple asie que c'est quand
même plus un peu plus intéressant que ça
une pièce mais c'est pour vous donner un
petit peu le lien entre abstrait et
concret ensuite très important il faut
avant de vous lancer dans des centaines
de milliers d'euros de travaux même un
seul euro de travail il faut pouvoir
tester votre pièce tester ou tester
votre jeu vidéo et ça ça se fait avec
des outils adaptés et là aussi il faut
penser et créer des outils adaptés
dans le cas des pièces en particulier on
fonctionne beaucoup par jeu de rôle
c'est vous êtes candidat on a quelqu'un
un testeur en face de nous vous êtes
dans une caisse
qu'est ce que je vois on lui explique on
matérialise les objets par des parts des
bouts de papier on procède par
libération ça c'est quelque chose qui
est très classique dans tous les projets
on teste on cliente est on modifie et ça
c'est le dernier point pour faire une
boucle avec la concurrence et partir du
moment où vous avez créé un produit
initial et à partir mais on a créé cette
première live heskey tout d'un coup bas
la concurrence arrive et tout d'un coup
la concurrence vous ressemblent beaucoup
parce que elle c est vous parce qu'elle
a le droit
et aujourd'hui on est à créer des
nouvelles pièces face à un système ultra
concurrentielle où tout le monde sait qu
aux pieds les uns sur les autres
donc comment on fonctionne parce que
c'est difficile de faire complètement
différent donc on a un système qui est
qu on prend les points communs tous et
toutes ces entreprises toutes ces
énigmes et ont fait différent des points
communs mais par contre quand il ya une
île singulière dans une pièce en
particulier celles là ont la garde
voilà je remercie beaucoup j'espère que
ça vous aidera